Trading has begun on China's new Nasdaq
style Stock Exchange and prices have
more than doubled on the Science and
Technology Innovation board of the
Shanghai Stock Exchange one company
angie micro electronics jumped by more
than 400 percent the so-called star
market has been launched in an effort to
boost the credibility of the country's
volatile stock markets 25 companies from
IT and other sectors are listed
China is the world's second biggest
equity market behind the US but it's
been criticized for high levels of
speculative activity and a lack of
government's governance
our reporter Clifford Coonan has taken a
closer look at China's new high-tech
market there's quite an impressive debut
has that been influenced by what's going
on in Hong Kong I think it has it's the
hugely significant event the launch of
this of this board but Hong Kong has
always had an influence on what happens
in China in terms of listings and the
Shanghai Stock Exchange in particular
certainly the uncertainty there in Hong
Kong now with the demonstrations will
will feed into a benefit I think for
therefore the new listing in Shanghai
the capital flood we're talking about
yes yeah I mean they're worried that
that Hong Kong will start to experience
capital flight investors don't like
uncertainty so they're going to say well
we've got this shiny new exchange in
Shanghai now so why don't we look at
look at there
that new star market well how is it
different from the regular market in
Shanghai well the regular market in
Shanghai is kind of a it's sometimes
seen as a bit of a casino it's how to
experience incredible fluctuations over
the years and it's also seen as poorly
governed decisions are made for reasons
that the markets don't understand
there's influence from areas that people
don't understand or don't know so this
seems to be an attempt to show that
there's more clarity about this and
there's also structural issues like it
it means it protects the founders of the
of the companies with with these voting
rights which means that actually in the
last few minutes we've or in the last
hour so we've seen some the newest
in areas in the world we can welcome
them to the international community of
billionaires so it has this M it has it
has a sort of a clearer cleaner
high-tech approach which I think the
Chinese government really really wants
to embrace how risky is it for you and
me to invest there I think it's still
any anything in China is still gonna be
risky it's gonna be very domestically
focused and so a lot of the things that
we take for granted in in the West about
transparency and when it comes to
companies for example and knowing what
way things are going you know you still
still doesn't clear about how much of
that we're going to get so it's still
gonna be it's still gonna be a risky
venture but the government has promised
to that there will be better governance
and in the short term certainly it's
gonna be a quite an interesting prospect
I think for investors it's China now
ironically a safer place for investments
due to stability well I still think
that's maybe it's certainly more stable
from I imagine the way investors are
looking at is to go back to Hong Kong
they see as more stability now in China
than they do in Hong Kong because of
what's happening there
at the same time Hong Kong still has
great transparency there's a couple of
big Chinese companies like Alibaba which
is supposed to be doing a second listing
there so we to see whether that actually
takes place and if if Hong Kong
continues to thrive I think overall Hong
Kong is still is still the place to be
for Asian investment for a lot of
investors but this this new Shanghai
exchange is definitely a game changer
clipper kun thank you